um when I do teach when I teach First
Amendment law I put up the YouTube or
the Twitter community guidelines and all
of them are unconstitutional if they
were if they were enacted by the state
now that's not actually such a bad thing
in some ways might be because our First
Amendment law is at such an extreme
internationally speaking but these you
know whether it's rules against
obscenity or against they may they ban
you know advertisement of guns and drugs
pharmaceuticals actually probably
illegal drugs too as well as incitement
hate speech and the like there's all
kinds of rules that these private
companies have naturally that would be
unconstitutional with the government
passed them the question is really where
do we go from here
where's for the platforms go where
should the government go and there are
three basic sources of reform the first
is the government right and we can see
that the US government with the
exception maybe of the limited area of
campaign finance disclosure doesn't seem
to be acting to regulate a political
communication online leave net
neutrality out of it for just a second
European governments though are rushing
to fill the void that the US is leaving
and so Germany passed its fake news bill
to make basically find the Internet
companies the the large Internet
companies 50 million euros for every
illegal speech act that occurs on their
platform right and you know we'll see
how that plays out secondly there's
platform self-regulation which is where
I spend a lot of my time sort of
thinking about this and that's you know
are the platform's going to an add to
those other categories of speech
regulation that I mentioned before with
new rules with respect to fake news or
hate speech and they have rules on hate
speech already and the like and they
have been moving since the 2016 election
quite nimbly I think even if not as far
as I would like them to do to try to
address some of these Democratic
pathologies and the final area is
self-help right some of you are
developers in the room right they
and we have a project at Stanford where
we're trying to develop more of this
technology what tools can users have in
order to combat things like fake news
like hate speech like you know like echo
chambers and the like
right or to combat BOTS so that you know
that an account is is about as opposed
to a human
[Music]